ce soir on revient sur la paire qui
embarrasse la france insoumise et qui
par des révélations explosives du canard
enchaîné concernant adrien cnas et son
épouse le député la france insoumise
adrien cap nas est visée par une main
courante à la suite de cette main
courante déposée par céline captens le
député publié un communiqué où il
annonce se mettre en retrait et admet
s'être livrés à des violences conjugales
rien qu'à tenace annoncent ce matin
qu'ils se mettre en retrait de sa
fonction de coordinateur de la france
insoumise le député elle est fille du
nord à nous avoir donné une gifle à sa
famille dans la foulée de nombreuses
réactions sont publiées mais celle de
jean luc mélenchon va particulièrement
faire parler adrien décide de tout
compte sur lui je salue sa dignité son
courage je lui dis ma confiance et mon
affection certains accusent alors
l'homme politique de ne pas soutenir
céline quatre mains c'est de ne pas
dénoncer les actes de violence du député
toutes les dernières révélations ce soir
dans des pmp
alors adrien capte ans déjà il était
présenté vraiment il est présenté comme
le poulain de jean luc mélenchon
mobiliser vraiment que ce serait lui
même le successeur de jean luc mélenchon
merci sophy de ravinel journaliste au
figaro que j'adore sophie j'ai rencontré
mercy série tour d'une rue et on s'est
rencontrés je faisais de la de la
trottinette et j'ai rencontré sophie
dans la rue dont on a discuté ensemble
longtemps un dimanche soir y avait
personne dans la rue c'est très marrant
je vous jure que c'est vrai on se
connaissait pas on a discuté ensemble et
on avait un self il exactement en dix
ans le figaro tpm télé valeur se
croisent saissac c est avec nous ce soir
et à douala vers new york ou ailleurs
pour s'offrir la tôle dit vraiment gros
coup de coeur et florian bon ça fait des
années que j'ai un coup de coeur pour
lui expert en communication politique
merci d'être là alors c'est vrai que
cette affaire tout le monde en parle
adrien quatre mains c'est vraiment le
poulain de jean luc mélenchon tout me
disaient qu'ils allaient prendre sa
suite et là il ya cette affaire karim
dont on la comprend pas bien qu'est ce
qui s'y passe et sophie est ce que pour
expliquer nos téléspectateurs il ya eu
des violences dans un couple voilà une
des violences forte répéter a priori
selon le
le responsable lui-même d'encadrer un
quatre mains ce qui a mis une gifle à sa
femme ils ont un enfant ensemble et puis
l'année une année s'y déroulent et on ne
sait pas trop ce qui se passe on en fait
on n'a que sa version à lui donc ce à
quoi sa version sa version c'est que il
était désolé du fait que céline sa femme
veuille le quitter et que par un
désolation il a eu des gestes violents
et auparavant un an auparavant il
s'était agacé contre elle on ne sait pas
pour quelle raison et il lui avait mis
une gifle voilà ce qui est impardonnable
et ce qui est un acte épouvantable et
dont il s'est excusé publiquement
maintenant on n'a que sa version à lui
et donc c'est une version de violence et
ça a fait beaucoup de bruit parce qu'en
fait sa compagne sa femme a déposé une
main courante elle ne souhaitait pas que
ce soit médiatisé
après évidemment la main courante a été
médiatisé c'est vrai que les insoumis
ont beaucoup critiqué la police est ce
qu'il ya eu des fuites est ce qu'il ya
eu c'est ça on n'en sait rien en tout
cas c'est sorti en même temps quand on
dépose une main courante et qu'on est
aussi un personnage charlie cool épouse
d'un personnage public ça sort plus
facilement on a su aujourd'hui qu'ils
avaient une anc est préliminaire qui a
été donc le parquet à lille a décidé
d'ouvrir une enquête ça veut dire ça
veut pas dire que c'est particulièrement
grave mais ça veut dire que le
parquetier ou la parquetière a jugé la
justice a jugé que ça nécessitait d'être
un creuset approfondie donc il s'est
passé quelque chose
voilà est donc là la france un soumise
par un de ce parce que je vous entends d
adrien kate moss était dirigée pour
prendre la suite de jean luc mélenchon 1
du condo fait oui le fait c'était un
d'efforts il est vraiment dans le clan
il est vraiment celui parmi les
successeurs potentiels qui manie le
mieux le verbe à l'assemblée il est
vraiment réputé pour ça c'est un homme
d'appareil il est dans le clan rapproché
et de fête ça a créé un bazar
complètement dingue et le problème c'est
que la première réaction de jean-luc
mélenchon n'a pas du tout été à la
hauteur alors justement va la voir mais
on va la voir la réaction de jean luc
mélenchon qui s'est énormément perdu ça
prend va revenir sur la ferme si vous
pouvez nous mettre le tweak mélenchon la
malveillance policère le voyeurisme
médiatique les réseaux sociaux sont
invités dans le divorce conflictuel
d'adrien et céline catnat adrien décide
de tout prendre sur lui je salue sa
dignité et son courage je lui dis ma
confiance et mon affection sur la série
que c'est incroyable de faire un tel
taux élevés là on va en parler bien sûr
avec toi dans un instant gilles sophie
nous a donné des éléments l'histoire ce
que tu as d'autres éléments qui sont en
cause ils sont plus ensemble donc me
paraît que l l'aiderait dans sa défense
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
d'abord il avait jacques dousselin comme
avocate commune tous les deux donc au
départ c'est un divorce difficile
d'accord qui est réglé avec une avocate
l'avocate des deux et céline les pouces
va déposer cette main courante sans
doute pour se prémunir en fonction du
divorce c'est à dire préserver ses
intérêts et dire voilà ce qui s'est
passé c'est vrai qu'elle ne souhaitait
pas que ce soit public mais moi à ce
qu'ils répondent que comme elle ne le
souhaitait pas ça n'aurait pas dû l'être
jeudi c'est faux moi je me félicite
qu'aujourd'hui quand ça m'a courante a
été déposée
on ne l'a pas enterrés dont lente et la
sophie nounou payet un instant nous
violences répétées oui ils se croient
scène de la con c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'il ya dans l'air sur les scènes ya eu
trois scènes une scène avec une gifle
une scène où adrien veut le téléphone de
céline et à ce moment là famille de sa
femme il se dégage visiblement
elle se blesse au coude et une scène où
il y aurait eu il dit elle elle m'a
sauté dessus et c'est donc il ya trois
scènes précises ça fait une répétition
un enchaînement et quand tu as eu la
main courante les policiers aujourd'hui
sensibiliser à sa une transmis à
l'échelon supérieur
ouais alors moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que quand même ils ont de la
chance d'être qui n'y sont aussi pour
que ce soit transmis à l'échelon
supérieur et je sais que dans la justice
il ya quand même des soucis de lenteur
des dossiers et là c'est vrai que ça a
été saisie très vite mais s'il ya eu au
sein de la teinte de la france insoumise
d'ailleurs comme chez les écologistes
parce qu'il ya une autre affaire qui est
en train de monter ce soir qui est celle
de julien bayou ou chez les socialistes
y met des cellules interne pour faire
justice eux même dans les parties si
bien parce que justement les personnes
ne veulent pas déposer plainte ou
déposées de main courante parce qu'ils
ont le sentiment qu'on ne répond pas et
le problème avec cette affaire c'est que
finalement ils sont pris au propre piège
de leur volonté de moraliser la vie
politique en brandissant des pancartes
en dix ans nous nous sommes des gens
intègres et c est là qu est ce qui s'est
passé avec la réaction de jean luc
mélenchon c'est la protection du clan
c'est même pas une réaction machiste de
la part de jean luc mélenchon pour moi
parce que effectivement il a été dans
des mouvements ouvriers dans lesquelles
effectivement la domination masculine
est assez net et encore aujourd'hui je
pense un mouvement lent bafin les vieux
mouvement trotskyste dont il a été et
est en fait cesser le clan adrien quatre
mains c'est vraiment cette incarnation
là est donc cette cellule qui a eu chez
eux aujourd'hui tous les soupçons on
peut enfin on peut avoir des gros
soupçon et notamment sur eric coquerel
qui est un autre député qui a eu aussi
des soucis ou tabaski avez aimé leur cas
ils ont lâché 1 e non il a toujours pas
moi je les ai eus au téléphone josien
ils ont un peu lâché oui mes jolis yeux
téléphone aujourd'hui il le faut dit oui
devant adrien oui il a toujours pas
d'info sur les accusations qui ont été
portées contre lui ils ont une vie se
disent et j'ai été écarté pour des
raisons politiques cette affaire donc
c'est un divorce voilà comment ils en
arrivent tout le temps sa déco
maintenant que c'est ensemble une 13 ans
13 ans alors aujourd'hui ils ont chacun
un avocat une avocate s'est séparé
maintenant et me l'ont dit qu'elle
essayait de l'idée dans sa communication
etc florian sais c'est quoi cette
histoire moi j'ai cru mois que voilà qui
j'ai pas compris ce qui se danse en le
dépensant communiqué c'est ça voilà ça
et donc et qui étaient signées de leurs
2 2 nom et c'était une version commune
pour dire maintenant laissez-nous
tranquilles c'est une histoire privée ça
ne vous regarde pas
et donc alors que moi je pense que les
violences faites aux femmes c'est pas
une histoire privée et que justement ça
nous regarde mais en l'occurrence et
elle c'était le signal qu'il lançait
tous les deux ensuite adrien 4 mars a
fait un communiqué ou là en revanche il
est tout seul et c'est sa version à lui
elle n'apparaît plus d'accord florian
c'est confortable de signer un
communiqué de presse commun puisque ça
laisse sous-entendre qu'il n'y a pas à
contester les faits qui sont présentés
c'est aussi confortable quand on
s'appelle adrien avec un tenace de
publier un récit comme il l'a fait en
misant tout sur la transparence et en
espérant pouvoir en récolter les fruits
pour imposer son récit sa version de
l'histoire dans les médias tout en
occultant un certain nombre de points
qui posent vraiment problème je suis le
premier c'est qu'il laisse supposer par
le vocabulaire qui l'emploie dans ce
communiqué de presse qui est à mon sens
très maladroit que les torts sont
partagés et c'est une difficulté quand
vous êtes soupçonné accusés ou que vous
reconnaissez des violences conjugales
ensuite il tout en de son discours qu'il
présente dans ce communiqué de presse il
ne cite pas le mot harcèlement par
exemple alors que entre les lignes il
est facile de comprendre qu'il reconnaît
être à l'origine d'un harcèlement contre
son ex femme et tous ces points ça fait
évidemment de cette affaire non pas un
fait lambda mais un fait politique
pourquoi parce que c'est quelqu'un dont
on a dit qu'il pouvait conquérir la
mairie de lille c'est quelqu'un dont on
a dit qu'il pouvait diriger l'un des
partis politiques les plus importants de
france c'est pas n'importe qui adrien 4
nantes est donc cette évidemment pas une
affaire privée et c'est évidemment un
fait public et politique qui a son
importance surtout lorsque ça concerne
directement l'un de ceux qui a été un
moralisateur sur ces questions qui a
présenté une vérité sociale sur ces
faits donc ça lui revient aujourd'hui en
boomerang et c'est d'autant plus
difficile à gérer pour son parti et j'en
termine la queue après la succession de
faits que l'on a évoqué il y à un
communiqué de presse de l efi qui est
extrêmement minimaliste ils en disent le
moins possible et tout de suite après ce
communiqué qui aurait pu être
intéressant du point de vue de la
communication de crise et saccagée par
la prise de paroles maladroites de jean
luc mélenchon qui lui se contente pour
faire simple de soutenir l'agresseur et
de saluer le courage celui qui a reconnu
avoir été agressé au oui mais au fond de
moi je suis scandalisé par tous les gens
qui minimise les faits en fait le tweet
de jean-luc mélenchon les gens qui
disent oui mais il est en plein divorce
il était en train de s'engueuler c'était
une haine commune est réciproque en fait
on s'en fout le mec il a levé la main
sur sa femme c'est honteux et un homme
qui lève la main sur sa femme c'est pas
un homme je suis désolé donc à partir de
son là et puis le débat une gifle à son
mari bah pour moi c'est un homme qui lui
de cette supériorité de en terme de
forces est honteux de frapper les femmes
quand on est un homme c'est tout il a
rien à faire à part se retirer et se
terrent franchement ça ne connais pas
l'histoire de la voile et o'neal a
reconnu ian fleming ça voilà rien que ça
en fait ça suffit a oui la question de
l'instrumentalisation elle et elle est
essentielle la danse qui nous intéresse
parce qu'effectivement c'est la
succession de jean luc mélenchon qui est
ouverte et donc c'est toujours la
question de la manipulation politique et
c'est le cas pour julien maio aussi ce
soir il ya une espèce de d'actions
coordonnées de personnes on parle est
effectivement de la difficulté
d'interpréter ces affaires là une action
coordonnée de personnes qui montent au
front contre julien bayou parce que la
même cellule a été activée par une ex de
julien bayou sur lesquelles il aurait
exercé des pressions lui me dit que
c'est une affaire réciproque que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et chez eux
aussi ils ont un congrès et donc c'est
terrible parce que finalement c'est
affaire de femmes battues qu'on nomme
battu puisque ça existe aussi y compris
dans les couples dans les couples
homosexuels il ya vraiment un vrai
dossier là dessus eh bien elles sont ici
instrumentalisée dans la sphère
politique alors gilles se cache on
parlait de l'aller 1-1 ce temps nous
aurions parlé de harcèlement aussi c'est
quoi cette histoire que vous prend pas
bien c'est quoi alors il aurait il là
puisqu'il en a parlé écrit une suite de
message à sa femme qui s'apparente
effectivement à de la pression du
harcèlement pour qu elle ne le quitte
pas on va résumer cette affaire privée
comme ça c'est à dire que c'est plutôt
elle qui était l'initiative de la
séparation et lui avoue tout fait pour
la retenir quand je dis tout fait je
justifie pas il lui a adressé visible en
des messages très pressant s'apparentant
à un harcèlement potentiel et il ya eu
cette gifle il faut savoir que pour le
moment le parquet a ouvert une enquête
pour le moment il n'est pas mis en cause
lui glace et or là mais s'il était
justifiable une gifle ça peut être une
amende et six est considéré comme de la
violence volontaire aggravé ça peut être
des années de prison ça peut être cinq
ans de prison une gifle très violente
violences volontaires plus ou moins
aggravé une gifle qui occasionnent des
dommages réels ça peut être des années
de prison donc on peut dire que sa
carrière politique aujourd'hui là à
l'heure où l'on parle elle est
extrêmement menacée d'être compliqué
pour le compliqué et ce qui a choqué
beaucoup c'est ce que vous disiez aussi
c'est qu'on a eu l'impression que la
france insoumise aux débuts voulait
sauver le soldat 4,9 mais ça ça a choqué
énormément y compris dans le premier
message de jean luc mélenchon y est
revenue en arrière d'ailleurs très vite
oui parce que trois heures après
exactement
il céline et adrien sont tous de mes
amis mon affection pour lui ne veut pas
dire que je suis indifférent à céline
elle ne souhaitait pas être cité à des
juifs est inacceptable dans tous les cas
adrien l'assument c'est bien donc
aujourd'hui on reproche aussi qu'ils
soient encore député valent rien qu'à
tenace est ce que vous comprenez qu'ils
sont encore député ou est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va il faut dire que lui qui
peut décider finalement est-ce que son
discours il va devenir inaudible quand
il va être assis sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale à côté d'autres
personnes qui sont féministes qui
défendent justement les droits des
femmes et tout ça franchement c'est ça
va être très très compliqué pour le pour
lui son avenir d'autant qu'il d'autant
qu'ils ont lui est entré aussi en chasse
entre guillemets contre d'autres en face
qui pouvait d'ailleurs gérald darmanin
même si a pas eu de suite ou selon
d'autres
il était à fond l'avion est donc le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce-qui dhien il est là en bas non
en fait et tous ses camarades tous ses
collègues à l'assemblée bas ils vont ils
vont ils vont être embêtés lui aussi et
comme c'est un mec droit je pense que ça
va être compliqué pour lui de continuer
c'est sûr et que va faire son parti
aussi est ce qui va se faire exclure de
l es fier ou pas sachant qu'on est
toujours en plus dans une concurrence au
sein de la nuit parce qu est cette
fameuse association des écolos des
socialistes et des insoumis à gauche en
vue les européennes et tout ça donc
avant tout un moyen de donner des leçons
démocratie de transparence
florian pour conclure donc qu'est ce qui
va se passer deux points c'est
évidemment compliqué pour lui de se
maintenir
j'observe souvent en communication de
crise qui lie à une sorte chez certaines
personnalités
de schizophrénie totale entre le
discours qu'ils portent et leurs actes
on l'avait vu avec cahuzac qui s'était
mis à lutter contre les paradis fiscaux
et qui avait lui-même des choses à se
reprocher et on retrouve un peu ça ici
avec des gens qui mettent en avant leur
lutte contre un phénomène est alors
qu'ils en sont auteurs dans un cadre
privé et ici la difficulté c'est à la
fois à la sincérité de son propos et de
sa démarche s'il assume qu'il reconnaît
qu'il fait là la transparence sur ce
faire il doit en tirer des leçons et
donc à quitter la vie politique de toute
façon on l'a vu avec tes genoux cahuzac
autant d'autres même dsk il est très
difficile de reprendre la place qui a
été la sienne après que de telles
accusations est été et quelle que soit
la nature et l'accusation ont été
portées contre vous parce que le monde
politique est ainsi fait que vos
adversaires s'en saisissent inverseur
vous déstabiliser et s'il y avait une
seule leçon à tirer de la communication
de crise qui est déployée la pour tous
les communicants politiques ou les
communes etc en crise et qu' il ne faut
plus nous faire le coup du mari quitter
la présentation des faits
dans le communiqué de presse d'adrien
quatre mains ce qui laisse supposer que
tout cela est lié à la violence ou
crucifié par la violence d'un divorce ça
n'est plus tellement acceptable
d'ailleurs au canada ou dans d'autres
pays ça ne souffrait plus ya pas de
raison qu en france on en soit encore là
en 2022